on sunday 01 peru barcelona suddenly doesn't have
the importance that other
players had and i didn't even care but that
with me or without me
efe is is is game day
[Music]
is the feeling that I have a lot of
time that I worked with  a genius
sincerely looks at working with
guardiola regardless of the situation it is
always surprising the more
the level of the game increases the more the
level of attention in the matches the more
relaxed and I believe the most
impactful in the relationship with guardiola was
when he said he was going to teach me
playing without the ball and you ask me with
a formula 1 with lyon I don't know how to
answer, I
just know it's more for me I always say
that he always takes a step forward
when you're thinking
this is what makes yours a lot easier
life
but the key also 11 guardiola who
won a gift in front or for him
it's not because we had an
agreement it
's that we won the
Spanish championship for him to win a chance
for us
playing in england against the english team
dean knows the atmosphere that is generated from the
difficulty that the opponent had and he
was convinced that engineering and
he told us i will always make you
win
them the opponent's he sang everything
that happened in the  the whole game that was going
to happen in the game he joined us if
they tie the game so we don't
change the way of playing because that's the
only way we'll be able to
win and we scored and they broke the tie
today he's very convinced and  he
made us believe here that we can make
it we made
it it is believed that we saw it without a doubt when
I was in barcelona it was one of the
things I most cherished that people
would only appreciate when that
team no longer had a game that is
what is happening now, the value of that team
was immeasurable at that moment and I
mentioned it now when you hear
words from someone who knows what he is talking about
what I thought at that moment and to
this day it is this p  point of madness in our
team, everyone and it doesn't have the
importance that I and other players
had, I didn't even care but that with me or
without me
there was no game